So now that I have a good
understanding of do_GET,
let's take this web server to the next
level with some post functionality.
Gets are good for viewing information
all ready on the server, but
posts are what allow the user to
customize their web experience.
Get requests happen simply by
visiting the URL in a browser, but
post requests from a browser require
data to be submitted, like with a form.
I'm going to add a post method such that
our server doesn't just say hello or
hola, but whatever the user
prompts as a salutation.
On the same level as my do_GET method,
I will create another method called
do_POST, which overrides the method in
the base http request handler
superclass, just like doGet.
I'll make another try except block,
similar to my do_GET method.
When I receive a post request,
I'll send off the response code
that indicates a successful post.
Next, I need to decipher the message
that was sent from the server.
In order to do this, I'm going to
use some message from the CGI,
or common gateway interface,
library in Python.
So I'll add import cgi
to the top of my file.
Let's take a look at the following
chunk of code I'm going to add.
This cgi.parse_header function parses an
HTML form header, such as content type,
into a main value and
dictionary of parameters.
After that, we check and
see if this is form data being received.
I then make a variable called fields,
which we use the cgi.parse_multipart
to collect all of the fields in a form.
Then I will make a variable called
messagecontent to get out the value of
a specific field or set of fields and
store them in an array.
I will call this field message here,
and when I create my HTML form.
So now that I've
received a post request,
I can decide what to tell the client
with the new information I've received.
I will create an empty string
named output again and
then add some opening HTML tags to it.
I'll have my server respond with,
okay, how about this.
And then return the first value of
the array that was created when I
submitted the form.
Hm?
Well you might be thinking, hey, you
haven't even created an HTML form, but
keep talking about it
in the post handler.
And you'd be right.
So I'll go ahead and do that now.
In this line of HTML code, I'm adding a
post request along with the header tag,
to prompt the user to input some data.
Here, I wrote the name of my input
field as message, to coincide with
the message field I'm extracting
data from in the post request.
I'm going to copy this line of code and
paste it into my hello and
hola get requests, so this form will
be present on their pages as well.
I will also separate out my opening and
closing HTML tags on
their own line of code.
Let me not forget to close the body and
html tags in my post handler.
Send the output out to the server and
print out the output for debugging.
In my exception block,
I will just leave it as pass for now.
Let's see these new changes in
action from the web browser.